an image is worth more than a thousand
words
so i'm gonna start my talk by stop
talking and show you a few images that i
recently captured
so by now my talk is already six
thousand words long and i feel like i
should stop here
at the same time i probably owe you some
explanation about the images that you
just saw
what i'm trying to do as a photographer
as an artist
is to bring the world of art and science
together
whether it is an image of a soap bubble
captured at the very moment where it's
bursting as you can see in this image
whether it's a universe made of tiny
little beads of oil paint
strange liquids that behave in very
peculiar ways
or paint that is modeled by centrifugal
forces
i'm always trying to link those two
fields together
what i find very intriguing about those
two is that they both look at the same
thing they are a response to their
surroundings and yet
they do it in a very different way
if you look at science on one hand
science has a is a very rational
approach to its surroundings whereas art
on the other hand is usually an
emotional approach to its surroundings
and what i'm trying to do is i'm trying
to bring those two views into one
so that my images both speak to the
viewer's heart but also to the viewer's
brain
let me demonstrate this based on three
projects
the first one has to do with making
sound visible now as you may know sound
travels in waves so if you have a
speaker
speaker actually does nothing else then
taking the audio signal transform it
into a
vibration which is then transported
through the air is captured by our ear
and transformed into an audio signal
again
now i was thinking
how can i make those sound waves visible
so i came up with the following setup i
took a speaker
i placed a thin foil of plastic on top
of that speaker and then i added tiny
little crystals
on top of that speaker and now if i
would play a sound through that speaker
it would cause the crystals to move up
and down
now this happens very fast in a blink of
an eye
so together with lg we captured this
motion with a camera that is able to
capture more than 3000 frames per second
let me show you what this looks like
[Music]
thank you very much i agree it looks
pretty amazing
but i have to tell you funny story i got
an indoor sunburn doing this while
shooting in los angeles now in los
angeles you could get a decent sunburn
just on any of the beaches but i got
mine indoor
and what happened is that if you shoot
again 3000 frames per second
you need to have a silly amount of light
lots of lights
so we had this speaker set up and we had
the camera facing it and a lot of lights
pointing at the speaker and i would set
up the speaker put the tiny little
crystals on top of that speaker and we
we would do this over and over again
and it was until midday that i realized
that i had a completely red face because
of the lights pointing at the speaker
and what was so funny about it was that
the speaker was only coming from the
right side so my right side of the face
was completely red and i looked like the
phantom of the opera for the rest of the
week
let me now turn to another project which
involves less harmful substances
has any one of you heard of ferrofluid
some of you have
excellent should i should i skip that
part
ferrofluid has a very strange behavior
it's a liquid that is completely black
it's got an oily consistency
and it's got tiny little particles of
metal in it which makes it magnetic
so if i now put this liquid into a
magnetic field it would change its
appearance
now i've got a live demonstration over
here
to show this to you
so i've got a camera pointing down at
this plate and underneath that plate
there is a magnet now i'm going to add
some of that ferrofluid
to that magnet
let's just slightly move it to the
right
now maybe focus it a little bit more
excellent
so what you can see now is that
the ferrofluid has formed spikes and
this is due to the attraction and
repulsion of the individual particles
inside the liquid
now this looks already quite interesting
but let me now add some watercolors to
it
those are just standard watercolors that
you would paint with you wouldn't paint
with syringes but
it works just the same
so what happened now is
when the watercolor was flowing into the
structure the watercolor do not mix with
the ferrofluid that's because the
ferrofluid itself
is
hydrophobic that means it doesn't mix
with the water and at the same time it
tries to maintain its position above the
magnet and therefore it creates those
amazing looking structures of channels
and tiny little ponds of colorful water
paint so that was the second project let
me now turn to the last project which
involves
the national beverage of scotland
this image
and also this one
were made
using whiskey
now you might ask yourself how did he do
that did he drink half a bottle of
whiskey and then
draw the hallucination he got from
being drunk onto paper
i can assure you i was fully conscious
while i was taking those pictures
now
whiskey contains 40 of alcohol
and alcohol has got some very
interesting properties
maybe you have experienced some of that
properties before but i'm talking about
the physical properties not the other
ones
so when i open the bottle
the alcohol molecules would spread in
the air and that's because alcohol is a
very volatile substance
and at the same time
alcohol is highly flammable
and it was with those two properties
that i was able to create the images
that you're seeing right now
let me demonstrate this
over here
and what i have here is an empty glass
vessel it's got nothing in it and now
i'm gonna fill it with oxygen
and whiskey
that's more
now we just wait for a few seconds for
the molecules to spread inside the
bottle
and now
let's set that on fire
so that's all that happens goes really
fast and it's not that
impressive i could do it again to show
it one more time but some would argue
that this is a complete waste of the
whiskey and that i should rather drink
it
but let me show you a slow motion in a
completely darkened room of what
i just showed you on this live
demonstration
so what happened is that
the flame would travel through the glass
vessel from top to bottom burning the
mix of the air molecules and the alcohol
so the images that you saw at the
beginning
they are actually a flame
stopped in time while it is traveling
through the bottle and you have to
imagine it was flipped around 180
degrees so that's how those images were
made
thank you
so
i have now showed you three projects and
you might ask yourself what is it good
for what's the idea behind it is it just
a waste of whisk is it just some strange
materials
those three projects they're based on
very simple scientific phenomena such as
magnetism the sound waves or over here
the physical properties of a substance
and what i'm trying to do
is i'm trying to use this phenomena and
show them in a poetic and unseen way and
therefore invite the viewer to pause for
a moment
and think about
all the beauty that is constantly
surrounding us
thank you very much
[Music]
you